eu transport ministers meeting at the  next tte council will discuss the fourth  railway package proposals  the package aims to remove the remaining  barriers to the creation of a single  european rail area encouraging  competition and innovation  ministers will look at proposals to  liberalize rail passenger services and  to strengthen governance of railway  infrastructure  the council will also look at ways that  transport can boost competitiveness  growth and jobs in the eu  over a working lunch ministers will talk  about the contribution of aviation to  jobs and growth in the context of the  upcoming aviation package